how's gum Brazos welcome to the more
duck adventures for Disney infinity so I
dug a little deeper this time and we're
gonna play some toy boxes made by other
Disney infinity players they're all in
the description let's go
how's that gum Rises Bear Paw today
we're gonna put at Donald what are you
doing hey you two welcome to my new crib
I got a fireplace it's not working now
it is got my Butler he takes all of my
stuff doesn't matter how many times I
give it to him it still takes it anyway
we're gonna play some of you bros
creations today I wasn't really too
impressed last time that was one cool
map so I don't want to I don't want to
be that guy let's begin
here we are first map what is this does
that do nothing great whoa look at that
hey where's my car hey it's Fitz that's
mine
no way oh yeah I'm so good at driving
pretty awesome let's pimp it out a bit
damn it Donald you what up I'm still
going never give up
hashtag never give okay you should
probably give up oh sorry sorry train oh
this is what you get for being a bad
train I love you train you're my only
friend
what even got the Lankan music matter
yeah ma ma me oh look
I am Simba right now except down on a
pole and all right hold me up Oh while I
display myself for their Lion Kingdom
that's right
I'm your new king there's bound to be a
couple changes from now on no more
killing of the ducks every Friday we
will have Sailor man day if anyone ever
goes near my monkey then please don't
scratch him all right that's it just get
Aang
Wow wait you're not real oh god damn it
this draw this is how the Lion King
should have ended
let's explore Oh No let's kill him
oops hey you scratch my car I scratch
your face stop attacking my poor car no
now stop my car has never hurt anyone
except that one time don't know they
keep coming recomm Donald look at it no
one messes with Donald I didn't think
I'd have to do this but I'll have to use
my secret my secret trick Dumbo
oh yay but wait but wait there's more he
has rocket Nunchuk recommed um buh
destroy Dumbo come down destroy we did
it so proud now we can fly that's a duck
through the sky yay so happy we have
liberated the people all two of them
oh my god I don't know I have to oh my
god it is so epic what's going on
oh my god I nearly became a fried
chicken which wouldn't make any sense
because I meant what duck but whatever
oh whoa what was that
what are they doing
ah alright let's grind baby woo duck
tales crude
oh god what do i do what do I do good
job Donald ha ha there's no mountain
high enough ain't no Valley low enough
for Donald Duck to become big Illuminati
no wait uh ok what happens here
ooh I do now
press to exit all right well that's cool
Donald what are you doing ah
Donald you little bugger all right what
do we got purge the evil castle and save
the land from darkness girl I do that
every day yeah no don't change
oh go down oh I believe in you Donald
I love you Donald but not in a weird way
Donald go Donald p.m. he's faced
oh god I'm so dead I knew
Oh oh yeah I did it look I did it oh god
what are you doing Dumbo what is this
mystery shank Dumbo is all about that
gift shop all right well I'll see you in
a bit
always is gravity falls I love gravity
falls it is gravity falls that phased
out what white
what the duck what oh my god this is
awesome what the oh yeah that's so cool
what is this let's go baby yeah yeah
jumping yeah come on already let's go
gimme aah oh my god it's so fast it's
over aah aah
ok my eyes can't keep up with this this
is amazing more Maps like this one
please
ooh underwater what now and we even get
the eyes demons sweet how did that work
anyway
can we do any backflips note to self
don't do backflips ever I should should
know this by now
oh yeah go Donald hundred percent are in
spas where as fast there we go we're
back baby oh my god all the front flips
all the front flips nailed nailed it oh
hello oh that's so cool
let's do another awesome one like that
one hey we're doing another gravity
falls co-ed lawyer
damn it Dumbo get out get off me calm oh
sorry
what am I good at this yes am I good at
video games front flip yes
yes
ah
what and God what did you do oh no sure
alright I think this little doggie wants
me to take him out for a walk so we're
gonna have to end it there bro this if
you enjoyed watching please hit that
like button and thank you for watching
after all after all it's not that bad is
it thank you for watching
that's a would bro